King new [__] die parodieren und sonst
die machen nach wenn wir das Interview
online haben dann Krallen die sich das
runter und machen Parodie D die sind
sensationell Parodien find ich irgendwie
geil Battles das ist super lustig so und
die heißen King you
[__] J kom money Boy geht wir sind King
[__] und wir haben zwei Fragen an Money
Boy
also nein jetzt mal im Ernst wir sind
King you [__] und wir haben zwei Fragen
an money Boys Swag Swag und die erste
Frage ist ja es gibt ja so viele moneyby
Parodien sagst du eher so ja m geil
Alter ich kann selber voll da drüber
lachen und find das richtig geil oder
sagst du ja so verpisst euch ihr nervt
voll ist die erste Frage ja und die
zweite Frage wäre und zwar sindimmer so
viele [__] in deem videootte nackte
[__] in deem Video und
würde uns interessieren wie deine
Freundin darauf reagiert ob sie
eifersüchtig ist ob es deswegen nur
Stress gibt oder ob sie das Okay findet
ja das war's wir sind auf deine Antwort
gespannt und grüße an Christoph Grüße an
moneyby peace peace diger okay also zu
den Parodien ich kenne viel
weniger moneyby Parodien als
wahrscheinlich die die meisten anderen
da
draußen weil ich ich habe irgendwie gar
keinen Bock ich kenne die Sachen die ich
mache und ich interessiere mich nicht so
wirklich für die Parodien ich muss
zugeben dass von manchen von den
früheren von von den ganz frühen
Parodien ich einige im Kopf habe so vor
allem zu steige aus dem Bett dreed den
Swag auf gibt so paar Sachen so Pinkel
nachts ins Bett blaba bla da gab's so
paar Tracks die mir selbst im Ohr Ohr
geblieben sind und so natürlich der der
lyrische
Swag kennst du nee hab ich noch nicht
kennst du noch gar nicht wo jemand das
so vorliest wie ein Gedicht und ja genau
der lyrische Swag und so das habe ich
echt gefeiert da muss ich wirklich
lachen und nicht so wie manche schreiben
lol und die Lachen gar nicht laut oder
so ich habe da wirklich gelacht bei dem
Video und ich habe den dann getroffen in
Wien auch bei einer meiner Shows
Backstage und hat mir voll die Props
gegeben und so er war voll der moneyby
Fan und das war nicht cool und ganz
ehrlich die meisten Sachen kriege ich
gar nicht an weil ich zu fokussiert bin
selber neue Sachen zu machen ich halte
mich da gar nicht lange auf und die
zweite Frage mit den [__] in den
Videos und so ob meine Freundin Eifers
süchtig wird
die ist selber großer großer rapfan und
und kennt natürlich all die Videos die
ich auch angucke
und sieht dass die Army Rapper haben
auch diese Art von Videos und das ist
einfach ein bestimmte Art von Lifestyle
und das bestimmte Art von in einem Video
ist halt das wie ein Film oder so da da
bin ich eine Art Schauspieler und ich
habe die Ladies da und die sind zwar
nackt und so aber es geht ja nicht
wirklich was ab und natürlich ist sie D
auch bisschen eifersüchtig aber meine
Freundin ist eher eifersüchtig wenn ich
irgendeinen Track mach so so ein
bisschen so ein romantischen Track und
ich Raap dann über Ladies und so und und
sie hat nicht immer das Gefühl dass
jetzt vielleicht um sie geht oder so und
dass ich alle möglichen Ladies in meinen
Tracks irgendwie so
Anmache oder so und dann ist sie
vielleicht ein bisschen eifersüchtig
aber sie ist generell nicht so
eifersüchtig und dum ist sie eigentlich
cool mit all dem und das finde ich
natürlich auch
cool